it has now been 7 months since AB inbev
flipped the bird to its customer base
and then doubled and tripled down on the
insult in the expectation that the
boycott would eventually collapse and
the customers would just forget and move
on and I am pleased to report that none
of that has happened AB inbev is the
world's largest Brewer it saw its
Revenue climb 5% in the July to
September period in line with Wall
Street predictions but ABM dev's Revenue
in the United States
did not grow it fell it fell by
135% Us sales of budlight were down a
full 29% over the four weeks ending on
October 21st compared to that same
period last year which means the boycott
has not L up